first of all you you look beautiful I'm
just thankful you're here because I'm
told that you almost missed your plane
my gosh okay so this is I can't believe
I play it I live in New York
and I work here a lot and I work in
Toronto where we do people of Earth is
you know and I play it super fast and
loose with with airports I'm I'm always
lucky I always land on my feet I have
TSA PreCheck which is the greatest
invention of all time you can you sail
through with your laptop in your bag
your belt on your jacket I always feel
like I should have like a little you
know tambourine like I'm going but it
was so bad you know who don't have it
are so mad angry that so mad it's really
good to walk by usually I'm very relaxed
about the airport and I couldn't believe
it I got in the car and this driver last
week he actually took a stand I'm not
even putting the words in his mouth he
and I and I'm quoting doesn't believe in
Google Maps doesn't believe in Google
Maps it's like it was like a personal
like a religion like a belief system yes
believe they didn't believe in Google
Maps and I wasn't really paying
attention I look at my phone and
whatever but all of a sudden I looked up
it in 45 minutes and we were about three
blocks away from my apartment study and
I said you know could you could you
could we turn on waste I don't I don't
believe in Google Maps so so what do you
think did he think it would like steal
his soul or something don't know but he
took a real hard line and I felt like I
shouldn't object right um because I
didn't want to like have a fight with
him or anything but I did I gently
encouraged him I tried to you know teach
him about my belief system which is in
Google Maps using satellites help find
out started anyway he called BS and I
miss my plane
yeah oh you missed your plane yes
because he because of this guy I've
never had it happen I couldn't have even
had to turn around it was a two-hour
what was it was it lift was it uber it
was a private car service but still in
yet I mean it was you know that the
company that I was working for a sense
so right all right yeah I'm an Avon rep
so my Avon
you